choosing to do this for your life is is
a big decision it's never guaranteed you
just have to really believe in yourself
and work hard and not expect anything
because as long as you give it your all
and you you know create the right
circumstances and I feel like you'll be
alright
so I'm des Klum and I'm 29 and I am a
singer I think like ever since I was a
young kid I was always obsessed with
music my parents always had you know
records lying about and always
introduced me to different genres of
music at first I don't think I realized
that I was actually a talent until
worked out that not everyone could sing
the way I could I went to do this
artists development course this girl
basically came in to do a talk and she
was speaking about her experiences and
her songwriting and people she's working
with I went and spoke to her after and I
was like I think you're really cool can
I get in a studio with you and we
started working together and we wrote a
song called home from the moment I wrote
that song I felt like everything kind of
fell into place nothing had happened
like it's not like I'd made a record
label or anything like that but I think
it was the first song that I wrote that
I felt like had meaning and represented
me as an artist and that taken like four
years I've been writing for so long but
it was you know trying so many different
kind of lanes and you know different
genres and sounds and and from that
moment everything changed something that
people might not know I always feel like
people think that if you're in the
studio you're making money and it's not
true you could spend two years going
into studios and like as a songwriter
you write a million songs and maybe one
of them could get cut and that's you
make your money and I don't think people
realize you write a lot of songs and you
do a lot of projects and you vest so
much of your time and your energy and
your love into things and quite often
more than not nothing becomes of it you
know everybody sees the single on the
album they don't see everything else
[Music]